je vous le disais dans les titres un
incendie s'est déclaré ce mercredi matin
au cœur du domaine de l'abbaye
Saint-Georges sur la petite commune de
Saint-Martin-des-Bois près de Montoir
pas de victimes à déplorer mais sans
doute de lourds dégâts au niveau des
combles et de la toiture d'un bâtiment à
tenant à l'abbaye l'ensemble appartient
audio 16 de Blois et servait de centre
spirituel on fait le point avec Faustine
Luneau
cet après-midi les pompiers tentaient
d'éteindre les dernières flammes
ravageantes encore l'abbaye
Saint-Georges l'opération a débuté dans
la matinée c'est l'homme en charge de
l'entretien de la forêt qui a vu des
fumées sortant de la toiture à 15h
l'incendie était maîtrisée mais les
dégâts sont conséquents pour ce bâtiment
classé au patrimoine l'intervention des
pompiers a permis d'éviter la
propagation du feu à l'église adjacente
mais la partie habitation est fortement
touchée l'ensemble des combles des 700
m² de la partie habitation sont
totalement détruites la les deux tiers
du premier étage aussi en fait par
l'incendie et la ruine en fait des
cloisons et des plafonds qui sont en
fait de torchis et de plâtre donc qui se
sont par résistance mécanique et
écroulées au sol du premier étage et
elle a notre objectif premier c'est de
préserver l'ensemble du rez-de-chaussée
dont des pièces avec on va dire des
tentures et du Mobilier mural je dirais
de boiseries de valeur du mobilier qui a
parfois pu être évacué et indiqué dans
un autre bâtiment quant aux trois
habitants du château le père Charles
Lenoir et deux personnes de sa
communauté de vie ils ont pu sortir
attend du bâtiment et ont été relogées
dans un gîte voisin mais c'est un coup
dur y compris pour la directrice du
domaine on vous sentez du coup de voir
ça effondré effondré parce que c'est un
lieu qui nous est cher c'est un lieu un
beau lieu pour le diocèse de Blois un
projet qui démarrait depuis 15 mois et
voilà donc c'est c'est un peu
heureusement il y avait personne à
l'intérieur donc ça c'est c'est déjà
encore merci le ciel pour cela
l'opération de secours va se poursuivre
cette nuit et des rondes de surveillance
devront être réalisés pour s'assurer que
l'incendie ne repart pas